It is my pleasure to introduce
Verity Price, DTM.
Verity Price
is someone who believes in
chasing your dreams.
She's gone from walking
750 miles across Europe in hiking shoes
in memory of her parents
to performing her original songs
in high heels in front of stages
that are packed in Nashville and New York.
From acting in what she admits might be
B-level movie films
with Steven Seagal and Sean Astin
to speaking on two TEDx stages.
She went from single at 40
to happily married at 43,
and became a mother
to a beautiful baby boy long after
doctors said it was impossible.
And then in lockdown,
she chased another dream
and in 2021, made history
as the first speaker from Africa
to be crowned
World Champion of Public Speaking.
With a
degree in psychology
from the University of Cape Town
and an Accredited DeBono Thinking
Facilitator, Verity
has presented to hundreds of companies
over the last 15 years.
In 2022, she was invited to be
a faculty member of the University of Cape
Town's Graduate School of Business,
rated the top business school in Africa.
Here,
she forms part of an executive education
department and delivers her content
as part of transformational work
they do with organizations
across the African continent.
When it comes to making your dreams
a reality, Verity believes
you need to act out of the box
more than think out of it.
And now, all the way from South Africa
to help us design our future and think
and think ahead for the crowd,
please welcome Verity Price.
Thank you, Conference Chair.
I've chased a lot of dreams in my life,
but I have to tell you,
not in my wildest dreams did I ever
imagine I would be on this stage
speaking to this audience
in The Bahamas.
So am I safe to say
there's a lot of dreams in the room today?
Yeah.
So if you've got big dreams, big hopes,
big aspirations, put up your hand.
Put the ace in the chat.
Put up two hands
if they're really big.
Okay, thank you.
Now, when you think about that dream
or that goal, put up your other hand
if you ever feel afraid, concerned.
What if it doesn't work out?
What if I fail?
What if something goes wrong?
Put up two hands.
If that feels really real.
Do you know what this means?
You're human.
Our dreams excite us and they terrify us.
But in the 15 years that I've been working
with hundreds of companies,
tens of thousands of people,
helping them to change their thinking
so that they can reach their dreams,
I've come to see
what really makes the difference
is if you are asking two questions
or giving one answer.
Have I got any parents here today?
Yeah. Some of you don't sound sure.
Do you know? Are you good parents here?
If you didn't say yes,
were you a child once?
Okay, so you know this.
When children learn to speak,
what is that irritating question
they ask all the time? Why? Mm.
And then when they become teenagers,
they change it.
They add another word. What do they say?
Why not?
Okay. They start pushing back.
I hear you and your rules,
and they push back.
And so by the time we're adults,
until we die, we have a one word answer.
What do we say?
Because. No. Because.
Have you ever said that before?
Because I said so.
Because those are the rules.
Because that's how it's done.
Because it's safer that way.
And before you know it, because becomes
the box. It becomes a reaction to life
where we survive, but we don't thrive.
Are you here because you want to thrive?
Yeah. Okay, good.
Has anyone ever told you
to think outside the box?
Yeah.
Well, I want you to consider that
all you need to think outside of
is the because, all the reasons
it can't be done,
and start asking,
"Why am I doing it this way?
Why not do it differently?"
and consider
all the reasons it can be done.
Now, you might be wondering
why is Verity so passionate about this?
I'm going to tell you. Twenty years ago
I was surviving the music industry.
I was an aspiring singer and songwriter.
I had big dreams.
I wanted to tour the world.
I wanted to top the charts.
I wanted to be interviewed on Oprah.
I didn't care what color her couch was.
Yes. Yes.
But two years into my career,
the only thing I was touring
was the bar at the end of my street.
So on top of that, I then discovered
it was going to cost me $40,000
to record my first album.
That was a big pothole
between me and my dream.
And my reaction to that
problem was to moan.
I became one of those people
who arrives at a party with their problem,
and then they find some poor person
and they spend the whole night
telling them how hard and
how unfair their life is.
Have you ever met someone like this?
I hope they are not sitting in your seat.
Eventually, I realized
I either needed to give up
or I needed to get creative.
Which is the better choice?
Get creative. Absolutely.
So I got on the phone to my older,
much wiser sister, Kay.
Now, Kay is the bookworm in our family.
I asked her if we could have coffee
and she arrived and told me that she'd
just finished reading a book called
the "Six Thinking Hats" by Edward de Bono.
She was excited
to see if she could use his framework
for problem solving to solve my problem.
Now, I don't have time to take you
through his work today,
but I want to take you through the
thinking we did that day.
The first thing we realized was that
I was so focused on my problem,
I hadn't looked up to focus on a solution.
And if you have got obstacles between you
and where you want to be,
it comes down to
are you asking extraordinary questions?
Because extraordinary questions
get extraordinary solutions.
And so my
extraordinary question that day was
how can I market
and release an album in South Africa
without going into debt?
I put my problem into the question.
I wanted to give my brain
a challenge to solve.
Next, we stepped back and looked
at the facts of my current reality.
What did I know?
What did I need to know?
Now I knew that I didn't have $40,000.
My bank balance agreed on that.
But I also knew that I had 200 songs
written.
I had a band. I had a website.
I had a network of supportive people.
Didn't know how you got music
into the stores, how you got music on
the radio,
but that mere
act of looking at the facts
showed me things I could be doing
to move closer to my dream.
Next, Kay said
to me,
"Verity, how are you feeling about this?"
But before I started, she said,
"Name the feeling.
Don't explain
the feeling."
Okay.
Well, I'm overwhelmed,
frustrated, anxious, irritated, scared,
tired. It was a very long list.
I'd had a long time
to build up some feelings.
But the amazing thing is,
is when you name a feeling
but don't explain it,
it just gets it out of your head,
puts it on the paper,
and clears up your mind to keep thinking.
Next, she said, "Verity,
what is working in your career?"
Now, this was embarrassing.
In two years, I hadn't once looked at if
anything was working.
But when I looked, I found it.
I have songs written.
I have a band. I have a website.
There's less competition in South Africa.
And when I focused on the positives,
I started feeling more positive.
Then she said,
"Okay, let's think how you have been
thinking for the last two years.
What's not working?" This was easy.
I don't have the money
and because I don't have the money,
if I borrow it, I'm going to go into debt.
Does this kind of thinking
sound familiar to you?
Yeah. Okay.
Isn't it interesting
how easy it is to look at all
the reasons you can't do something?
But here's the beauty.
If you look at the positives
before you look at the problems,
it's much easier to then
consider possibilities.
And so I suddenly looked at everything
we'd written down and I went, "Hm.
Just because I don't have $40,000,
it was a problem and a fact,
why not leverage off
the fact that my songs are written?
I have a band. I have a website."
And imagine, now you know
you are accessing creative thinking
when you say things like "Imagine"
or "Wouldn't it be amazing if...?" And I went,
"Imagine if I asked everyone
I know to go onto my website
and buy copies of my album
before I record it.
Imagine
if I sell something that doesn't exist
and the people who buy it replace the record
label."
Now Kay was an amazing thinking partner.
She said,
"That's awesome. What else could you do?"
Because here's the thing with thinking,
it is far easier for you
to tame a wild idea
than it is for you to make a boring idea
interesting.
Okay.
So I said,
"All right, this is pretty different.
Don't know if it's ever been done before."
And I said, "Well,
maybe I can make a difference."
And I decided that I would give 10% of
everything I raised to split it
between women's shelters in South Africa
and empowering other artists.
Two years I had been stuck.
Thirty minutes of thinking differently
and I had a way forward.
I was going to sell an album
that didn't exist,
people
were going to replace a record label,
and we were going to give 10%
to empowering artists and uplifting women.
Now you might be looking at this
and going, "Well,
Verity,
isn't that just called crowdfunding?"
And you'd be right.
But do you know what
this idea was called in 2005?
Crazy.
I left that coffee
knowing I would be crazy not to try,
and I also left with a choice.
Was I going to act on my idea or leave it
written on a napkin?
Because ideas have no value.
Action has value.
And if you are prepared
to flirt with failure,
that's the only time you're ever going
to get to dance with success.
And so the first action I took was
I started telling people about my idea.
Two things happened.
Everyone in the music industry
said, "That won't work
because that's not how music is funded."
Everyone who wasn't in the music industry
said, "Why not?
That's crazy.
Let's do it."
First person who said yes was a guy.
His name was Guy, funnily enough.
We met at a dinner party.
He heard I was a singer.
He said, "Do you have an album?"
I said, "No, but I have an idea."
And while I was speaking,
he reached into his pocket,
pulled out his wallet,
and said, "I'll take the first copy."
And I kind of looked at him
and I looked at the money,
and then I asked the obvious
question, "Guy, why are you supporting me?
You haven't heard me sing."
He said, "Verity,
isn't that the point of your project?" Yes.
Give me that money.
But in that moment, Guy
taught me a life changing lesson.
And that is that your word creates
your world.
The way you speak about your goal,
your dream, where you're going,
that's what determines
who shows up to help you get there.
And the more I told people
I was selling an album that didn't exist,
the more I sold it.
So very long story short,
over 2000 people in 25 countries
bought that album.
I released it in 2008.
They sent me pictures, poems, postcards.
I even got a proposal
from a guy in Edinburgh,
but I think he wanted
to make more than an album,
so I said no.
As a result of them saying yes to my idea
and to my dream,
we were able to give over $4,000
to charity.
I could buy supplies for the shelters.
I could pay for two singers
to record their demos,
and one of them, Mimi Ntenjwa, pictured
there in the middle,
went on in 2010 to be named
Best Young Jazz Artist in South Africa.
Isn't that amazing?
So I'm just going to address
the elephant in the room.
You do know that I'm
not a famous pop star.
I'm still open to that interview
with Oprah,
just saying.
But what happened with this project
was that I got better known
for thinking than I did for singing.
I was suddenly being asked to speak
all over the world and I'd say, "Wow,
can I bring my band?"
And they'd say, "No.
Come teach us
how to think ahead of the crowd."
Because ultimately, that's
what people were interested in.
They were documentaries
and news articles worldwide.
It was one of the first online
crowdfunding projects.
HSBC Bank in the UK put it at number
25 of their top 100 business ideas,
and Cape Town singer Verity
even appeared in "Carte Blanche,"
the James Bond novel by Jeffery Deaver.
I don't know if you know what that means.
I'm officially South Africa's first
Bond girl.
But the most unexpected
thing that happened
was when I got sent a picture of Edward
de Bono, the author of "Six Thinking
Hats," holding a copy of my album,
holding proof that I'd acted on the idea.
Kay and I met him on his last
ever visit to South Africa,
and he invited us to teach his work,
and it changed my life.
Now, imagine
if I'd never acted on that idea.
None of this would have happened.
Now, it's not the path
my soul or my ego wanted for me.
I wanted to be a pop star,
but what I've learned is that sometimes
when you get onto the road
that your soul has planned for you,
life gets so much easier.
So I want to circle back to your road,
to that dream
that you put your hand up about earlier.
And I think you'll agree with me
that when it comes to chasing your dreams,
if you don't design your future,
someone or
something else
is going to design it for you.
And do you want to design
your future? Here, at home,
I hope at home it's also saying yes.
Do you want to design your future?
Yes. Okay.
Let's look at how you do
that. Here's the framework.
Hold that dream in your heart
and now I want you to look to the horizon
of that dream and get very clear
on what is your desired outcome.
You need to frame this
as an extraordinary question.
"How can I?" and then put some stretch in it.
This question needs to make your brain
a little bit uncomfortable
so that it can get creative.
When you've got that focus,
step back and look at the
facts of your current reality.
And then
take some time to check in
with how you're feeling.
But please remember, name the feelings.
Don't explain the feelings.
You're getting this.
And then I want to ask you
to spend a lot of time.
Don't wait two years to look
for the positives of what's happening
with regards to your dream.
Look for the positives,
what's working, what's going for you?
How can you leverage that
to take you forward?
And then get very honest
about what's in the way?
What are the weaknesses,
the pitfalls, the potholes, the problems?
And then I want you to fill
those potholes in with your ideas.
It helps to invite the Kay in your life
to help you with this.
I find having a thinking
partner makes a big difference.
But this is where you need
to have wild ideas that you can tame
rather than boring ideas
that you try to make interesting
because when you have that idea
and it excites you, it delights you,
it ignites a passion in you,
that's when you have to act.
That's when you have to dare
to flirt with failure.
That's when you have to let your word
create your world.
And I'm not going to tell you it's easy
because it's not. Dreams of things we do
when we're awake,
not when we're asleep,
but when you step out your comfort zone
and you see where it can take you,
it can be a life changing journey.
So is that a journey that you want to go
on to make your dream a reality?
Yes, yes. Yes, yes.
I see
Lisa Nichols is going to be with
us all weekend.
Yes, yes.
So I want
you to really take this forward with you
is that your thinking that you do today
is affecting the results you get tomorrow
and every day you have the choice
to look at the problems
you're facing
and think about them differently.
So my Toastmasters here, my Toastmasters
at home, what I want to ask you,
and I just want to get the buy in from you
that you are going to do this.
Let's see, I'm switching
mics. We're going to get interesting here.
Are you ready to design your future?
Are you ready to think ahead of the crowd?
Are you ready to get onto the road
that your soul has planned for you?
Well, to help you on that journey,
I'd like to leave you with a soundtrack,
something that you can sing
while you start walking.
And I've lost them. They're going
to play it for me very nicely.
I've got amazing,
my band is at the back of the room.
They're going to give us,
they are going to give us a song.
Would you like a song?
Can I finish with a song?
This is my invitation to chase your dreams
because you'd be crazy
not to try.
Maybe I'm crazy thinking that this might
work. Maybe I'm crazy
wanting something that might hurt.
Maybe it's madness to start
something that might end.
Maybe it's easier
to just not begin.
I may be delusional
believing this stands a chance
when so many before have proved
that good things don't last.
Seems a little bit
naive to step in anyway,
but I'd be crazy if I didn't
take a step around the corner
confronting all that
I don't know.
The storms, our weather,
those times of being out of control.
Not having all the answers
is never a reason not to try.
What if the Wright brothers
hadn't believed that they could fly?
I believe that we can fly.
You'd be crazy
not to try.
I hope you get out there.
I hope you chase your dreams.
You give yourself permission
to think ahead of the crowd,
and when you get there, please
send me a poem, a postcard, and a picture.
Thank you, Toastmasters.